i have i haven't i have a question okay
do you think it's okay to say things
like men are trash
i feel like yes and i have a reason
because okay why
statistically like men have been trashed
for so long
for so
for so long men have been doing like
really bad stuff like saying men in
trash like mental trash is okay but do
you feel like
you know like you're gonna be like in a
jokey way you've gotta be like okay like
this is not like i don't really mean
like you're trash like you're like okay
so what if what if guys said women are
[ __ ]
like in a joking way
i mean
like personally but they they kid you
know what i mean yeah i think is that
it's kind of in the same plane like it's
in the same domain like the same kind of
you really do you think people would
have the same reaction so if i said men
are trash and he says women are [ __ ]
like do you think it'd be the same like
you know fair enough
you know what's weird because if someone
was like that's very weird because if
someone said women [ __ ] i'd be like oh
if someone said yeah no but if someone
said women are hoes i'd be like okay
like that's very different
language yeah
yeah there's this i don't you're
american so i don't know yeah you know
like degrassi
where they were like i i'm sure that's
canadian
like there was this thing where it's
like tears claire i didn't know you
could get such a yeah i didn't know you
could get that from a [ __ ] and everyone
was like oh my god he called our whole
life yeah and i remember this whole
thing that's very weird because like i
call my close female friends [ __ ] and
it's like oh my god you [ __ ] like
like when it's like that we're like i
think especially straight men and it's
like oh you're a [ __ ] like or like
women always it's like i just do i just
don't understand like why do we make all
men pay the price for a small percentage
of men like why don't you see what you
said yeah you see what you said about
the question yeah um is it okay for me
uh guys to say yeah
so
think about like this show
if women and
correct me if if you guys disagree in my
opinion if women
say to men or men are trash we're good
just going to look at you and blow okay
yeah
yeah some guys do get take it personally
but it's not the majority of the guys
it's too common of a phrase for the
majority of the guys we're going to look
at you in black okay that's all we're
going to say bear in mind we're probably
thinking a bunch of things but wasn't
that okay yeah but if we call if i go on
the street right now obviously
go to a random woman not random woman
but let's just say i go to
someone i kind of knew
you're a [ __ ] she's gonna blow up like
like i feel like she would blow up those
are two very different i mean this is
the difference i feel like women say men
are trashed like their faces a lot it's
kind of like in that realm of like yeah
like ah men are trash but like a man a
man would like to another man like that
woman's a [ __ ] it's more like like no
but i'm talking about saying it to them
because usually when women say men are
trash they are you say they say to your
face
if we were to say that
we're gonna have a fight like and not
it's not the guy i fight and the woman
is going to be the woman trying to fight
a guy like
we
don't care as much do you think men
aren't trash i think everything is trash
i think everybody is a hypocrite i don't
think women are better than men because
you're acting you're acting like men are
on a lower like moral high ground than
women because men men also built the
world
like the world we're living and men
built that's kind of different though
because it's kind of like women didn't
have the chance to build the world like
the kind of the roles that we had in
that position statement i personally
feel like that's a pact okay do you
but like even men still run the world
today and we have the opportunity now
women are building infrastructure
they're not building the buildings
they're not doing the plumbing they're
not doing the electric they're not doing
all the things that make society run
what do we do marketing we do
people-to-people jobs that are expect
like men still run the world
so like
like even even you're talking about like
men like did all the atrocities they
also
were the ones like doing the great
things too i'm not saying like women are
like completely innocent in the whole
world and like everything that happens
on in the concept of society i think
that like i do think there's like many
instances that men have been trashed and
i'd like to say it it isn't that
politically incorrect i don't think it
is but there's also many instances where
women have been trashed
absolutely so so so
so like there's there's instances where
women put send men to jail where they go
to jail for false like grape accusations
absolutely unacceptable so so why why is
one acceptable like why like calling a
woman a [ __ ] it's not the same as
calling a woman trash so you can call a
woman trash that's fine i call it a man
trash is fine but
yeah like there's a lot especially in
britain yeah yeah and it's like with men
there's like
a dick there's like
like [ __ ] boy yeah yeah yeah like
progression to that and that's very
recent and like a lot of and it's like
if you say [ __ ] it's like a manhole and
it's very i think that's interesting not
like like socially i think that's
interesting like how many words
linguistic there is to like degrade a
woman in comparison to a man i think men
are trash that's like like a woman's a
[ __ ] it's like oh that's like there's a
different plot there's a different
they're like menotrash it's like men
exist and they're horrible like men yeah
exist and then women like a woman's a
[ __ ] that's like she's promiscuous and
horrible and that's like a that's like a
historically like demonizing thing for
women but at the same time men of trash
is like
but should we be demonizing women for
being promiscuous
but men of trash is like demonizing men
for like existing yeah
calling a man trash is like demonizing
him for being for doing bad things but
calling a woman [ __ ] is like luminous
and have been promiscuous and being
promiscuous shouldn't be demonized
anymore well
no when you say men are trash like
people just say that to say it it's not
even for it's not even like
i've said that after having a bad day
like so yeah yeah
and even and even like
i mean i i i think society would be
better if women didn't sleep around as
much actually you think so yeah what do
you mean by that though especially if
women don't sleep around enough then
there wouldn't be any children oh men
only that's not true that's not true
women are having more sex than ever and
there's less kids than ever so women
have mistakes than men that'll be
soreness of you yeah i do agree with
that like
yeah yeah but if women stop having like
sex then men will stop having sex you
know what i mean that's kind of like no
no
i'm not saying stop having sex but like
i feel like as women we try to like
reframe stuff
so it's like oh we don't like that
there's a double standard right with the
with the body count and sleeping around
whatever and we try to change the
definition but people feel how they feel
about it and there's a reason things are
the way they are like it doesn't it
doesn't benefit women to sleep around it
like because less guys want to date you
the more like if you like no guy wants
to get with a girl that's you want to go
with a date a girl wife or girl that
slept with all your friends
no yeah yeah
[Music]
but it's like we it's like we lie it's
like we lie to each other though because
as girls we know deep down that like
it's not appealing to guys if we sleep
around we know that and so why do we
tell each other that that it is i think
it's like coming from the idea from the
beginning like this idea of femininity
or like feminism is like being like the
man to be respected and to be like at
the same level to be equal i'm going to
start acting like a man in the way like
i'm going to be right no that's your
obsession yeah yeah that's exactly we're
going to be equal someday but i don't
think it's like that but like it's just
like a product of that kind of feminism
no and it's and it's i think it's
harmful to women because you give these
girls this bad advice
even though we and it's and it's it's
hard because we know like you know deep
down that like that sleeping around has
consequences it's more for women than
for men but we still tell the younger
generation of women to do it why
um i do notice a lot like media like
sleeping around is kind of like a big
thing like for women like now like i see
on tick like women like everyone like
sex work and things like that i don't
know how healthy it is especially for
young audiences right and like the main
people and the idea they're trying to
say like sex work is real work no it's
not why are we
it should be demonetic i'm sorry because
i think it's bad advice to the next
generation
yeah
i think it's just dangerous advice i
feel like yeah yeah especially like
people on tick tock like what what is
like the like main age range like an app
like that like maybe like 13 or 15.
entertaining yeah like they're seeing
that kind of content i don't think it's
healthy no i agree like okay i'm
thinking that that's normal because i
see it so often like yeah like maybe sex
work is like
easy or fun i don't think it's like
realistic because when i think of sex
work like that's like a last resort as
someone who's like that i'm not gonna
get into it like somebody's like done it
that it's like last resort it's like no
it's not like something like you're a
child you don't that shouldn't be yeah
that should be fun and and how many
girls turn 18 and start an only fan yeah
i think we're both
but we're in this society where we say
don't judge no judgment whatever because
you know i think especially as women
there's a part of us that like
we want people to feel included and we
have empathy and i think that's a good
trait but like it goes too far because
we start lying to each other
there's a car there's a big cost more
for women than for men to doing and only
fans and the type of
subscribing to these only friends i do
feel like it's like very enabled like
men's i don't feel like men are like in
a part like responsible for this like
increasingly they're the audience like
there's not a lot of women there
like oh yeah like
we they don't like saying that we women
to be that way but like you watch like
videos well that's because women are
portrayed
but we don't tell we don't tell young
women there's a difference between
sexual attention and relationship
attention like you can go like i could
go take off my clothes tomorrow and go
on instagram and get a ton of sexual
attention but would any of those guys
want to marry me yeah and so it's a
different kind of value yeah right and
that's what i'm saying like like these
conversations we don't have with like
the younger young girls and so they get
confused because they think by like
doing the sex work taking off their
clothes and being more promiscuous more
guys will want them and they will in the
short term
empowering when it's like it's but it's
also kind of dangerous but yeah younger
and yeah there are girls that start only
fans when they're under 18 and they get
themselves and other people in trouble
romanticized i feel like shouldn't have
roman decides this whole sex work thing
i just don't think it's true
i do think it's romantic that you see it
in lots of films you see it on tick tock
like people like oh like i've got sugar
daddy he's taking care of me but that's
a really dangerous environment for a
young woman and and they also lie
because they'll say they have to do
nothing together
it's a lot they're gonna get messages
and messages can be explicit i don't
think that's nothing i thought you're
gonna be receiving and not even that
like the girls that talk about they get
sugar daddies and they'll claim they
don't have to sleep with him
for how long
because no guy is going to be funding
your whole life just a chat just just to
hang out with you there's there's
nothing is free
but i just as girls we like lie to each
other it's the same thing with the body
positivity movement and i think it comes
from a place of empathy right because we
don't we don't want people to feel
excluded and like we have that like
motherly
you know part of us but it's lying to a
girl to say you're gonna get more
options with guys by gaining weight like
if i gained 100 pounds i'm sorry the
guys that are interested in me today
probably wouldn't be i think that's
different though because i think that's
in terms of media that's something where
a lot of people were like it's a thing
of like
skinny girls and girls at work like
there's different spring being fat and
being bigger and like like bigger girls
were like kind of categorized into fat
and characterized into oh ha ha look at
her she's fine wants to get with her and
i've actually seen the effects of that
into younger women and i think plus
sized
positivity positivity
is a somewhat good thing i think there's
a difference between plus size and like
obesity and like dangerously like big
like in terms of like
like representatives
yeah but like also like i think yeah
it's just that thing of like the
difference between plus size and obese
where it's affecting your health and
affecting yourself no i i actually agree
because i like you know i'm built like
an athlete like i'm i'm tall right so
like i remember the early 2000s like
white chicks you know the movie
no but all the girls in there it's like
they're so skinny and i'm just not like
built like that so i get what you're
saying but now like if i googled plus
size model do you think the majority
would be obese or do you think they
would just be an athlete like thick
and i think yeah i'm not talking athlete
fake like someone who is kind of like
fat but they're not like like it's not
affecting their health it's not
affecting them as a person if they want
to be
like that they shouldn't have to the
point where there are you know like eeds
and suicidal tendencies and stuff that
like affect their lives just like you
know like just because i've seen that
with people you know from social media
or media or stuff
like i've seen that happen where someone
who is you know like i'm not you know
i'm not gonna out them whatever but like
there's i've seen someone who because of
uh the expectations of someone and what
their body should be like they've been
kind of really like down on themselves
that's why i say i think a lot of these
movements come out of a place of empathy
that's what i'm saying like i think it
comes out of a place of empathy where
you know like i kind of relate to that
with what i was saying earlier
because you know i was always healthy
when i was younger but
you know i just think i agree with you
not yet but but i'm saying now like even
even what you're saying where they're
fat and it doesn't affect their health
it doesn't affect their health while
they're young
but but when they turn 40 is is it gonna
be the same
and it's like lying by where we're like
putting these girls on the covers and
almost encouraging
body positivity saying guys will still
like you but it's like the guys you
don't want are gonna like you
[Music]